good morning believe nation today's
message is put the right people in the
right positions over to you Larry
Ellison suddenly we hit a wall we reach
a billion dollars in revenue and we were
having serious management problems all
over the place and the people who were
running a company at the billion dollar
company were the same people that run
the company when we were a 50 million
dollar company one-twentieth the size
and I had an incredible sense of loyalty
to those people who worked with me to
build Oracle and it was a very painful
realization in 1990 that I was going to
have to change the management team that
the company had outgrown the management
that people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company I'm not
necessarily those are the same skills so
they're just different not one is better
or worse than just entirely different
skill set in running a 50 million dollar
company and then a billion dollar
company and both skill sets are rare and
precious but we needed a different group
of managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means I had to ask people who I'd
work with for a decade to leave my to
fire people and that was the most
difficult the most the most difficult
thing I had to do and in business asking
them yeah a bunch of people to leave
Oracle one of the most difficult
challenges of being an entrepreneur and
building a team and running a company is
gonna be your team right as you grow
your impact on the business goes down as
a percentage of what your team does your
role as one man in or one woman in a
hundred person company you're not doing
as much you know adding as much value as
when you're a solo entrepreneur and so
if you want to really grow it's going to
be about the team that you build their
abilities to contribute towards your
goal and do their job and are really if
the way and so getting the right people
on board is really paramount and then as
they grow giving them positions that
meet their skill sets their desires
their ambitions I want to share a quick
story of a guy who's on my team named
Ray I first met ray through his
girlfriend I hired his girlfriend and
over time she started slipping she
wasn't doing a great job maybe she had
personal issues and her work quality was
declining to the point where I was about
to fire her and Ray took over for her as
she left and moved the country I forget
what happened there and Ray took over
and my expectations for Ray were really
low I gutted a lot of the position to be
only really minimal stuff that we're not
of super high importance to the business
because of the responsibilities that
this woman could not keep up with Ray
then blew my mind ray then not only did
all those responsibilities in an amazing
way and started giving me feedback and
new suggestions and new ideas to the
point where then I wanted to give him
more assignments and more tasks it
increased his responsibility and now to
the point where you know ray is in the
Philippines and he was initially hired
to do just administrative really low end
stuff now he's being groomed and
promoted to be come in charge of my
entire website and so that's a major
promotion for him where most people
might have a North American team and an
outsourcing to the philippines where now
I'm taking somebody from the Philippines
making him in charge of the North
American team and that's because he's
just gone over and above and I've got to
groom him and train him and get him
ready to to take on that role it's not
gonna happen overnight but it's just a
matter of recognizing the talents on
your team and doing an ongoing
evaluation of how can I stretch this
person or not are they willing to take
feedback are they willing to grow and do
I always have the right people in the
right positions and asking that question
to yourself and trying to push your team
on a constant basis to get better will
help you fill out your management group
and build an organization that can
really get amazing things done and you
can be proud of so get the right people
in the right
positions believe so my question that if
you guys today is do you have the right
people in the right positions and the
second question is who is the first
person that you hired and what are they
doing for you whether it's full-time
part-time you know hour a week
freelancer I'm really curious to find
out leaving the comments below
and I'm gonna join a discussion thank
you so much for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an espresso